ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA POWER QUE HAN BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERON RIO CERVANTES CHEN CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DAVIES FLORA MIKE PRONGER
VINCE FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY LIII
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA NGUYEN
HELLO. PATTERSON LAWRENCE QUIRK
QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS REYES LOOSE
REEBOKS ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SEYARTO
SMITH STONE TAKING RELATIVE
AREAS BE APPROVED LAW VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
OKAY MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
EVERTEC QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. DES PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
. IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR.
AND THE NAME OF GOD THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL. ALL
PRAISES FOR GOD THE LORD OF THE
WORLDS THE COMPASSIONATE THE
MERCIFUL. MASTER OF THE DAY OF
JUDGMENT. OH GOD YOU ALONE WE
WORSHIP AND YOU ALONE WE CALL ON
FOR HELP. OH GOD GUIDE US TO THE
STREET PASSED. THE WAY OF THOSE
WHOM YOU HAVE BLESSED NOT OF
THOSE WHO HAVE EARNED YOUR ANGER
. WHO HAVE EARNED YOUR ANGER.
FOUR OF THOSE WHO HAVE LOST AWAY
. WE PRAY WE PRAY THAT YOU GUYS
THIS NOBLE BODY OF MEN AND WOMEN
TO SEEK JUSTICE AND EQUALITY FOR
ALL. FOR YOU SAID MANKIND WE
CREATED YOU FROM MALE AND FEMALE
. AND MADE YOU INTO NATIONS AND
TRIBES. THAT YOU MAY KNOW AND
HONOR EACH OTHER. INDEED THE
MOST HONORABLE OF YOU AND THE
SIGHT OF GOD. IS THE MOST
RIGHTEOUS I MEAN. THANK YOU
MA'AM AND SIR WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
. PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER GRACE. PLEASE JOIN
IN THE PLEDGE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. THE
STATE'S. ZERO SAN. S. THANK YOU
MAY BE SEATED- READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY
TRIMMER SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MARCH
EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY TO THE
ASSEMBLY BETTER AT SEVEN AM THE
AUDIBLE KELLYSAY ARE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIXTY SEVEN
SISTER PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK SHE
PROGRAM A DESK CLERK DAVID
HONORING LOCAL FALLING REPLACED
ONE OF THOSE REYES MOVES AND
MISS DAVIES SECONDS. AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS AT PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ. AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. AND MAY
ISRAEL S. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BONTA LEVY UP WITH ONE AND
MEDINA TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
SPEAKER RENDON AS AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN TO HAVE GUESTS AND
A PHOTOGRAPHER ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I MOVE TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO WITHDRAW S.
C. R. EIGHTY TWO ATKINS FROM THE
RULES COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY TO TAKE
UP THE RESOLUTION TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADOPTION. MISS DAVIS
FOR WHAT SERVICE WE ASK FOR
INJECTION AND ASK FOR A ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE MISS DAVIESS
WITHHOLDING. UNANIMOUS CONSENT
ASKING FOR A ROLL CALL. MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE ON
SUSPENSION OF THE RULES MS REYES
MOVES. AND MISTER GIBSON SECONDS
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. A
PROCEDURAL VOTE MS RAMOS IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MISS
DAVIES IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
MS RACES ASKING FOR AN I. AND MS
DAVIES AND NO. YEAH IT'S. THE
THIS TAKES THIRTY NINE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL EYES FORTY FIVE
KNOWS THIRTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. AND MS REYES YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO WITHDRAW SB ONE
EIGHTEEN AND SB ONE NINETEEN
FROM THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
ORDER THE BILLS TO THE THIRD
READING FILE TO ALLOW SIMPLY
MEMBER TEAM TO TAKE UP THE BILLS
TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. AND MS DAVIS FOR HER WE OBJECT
AND WE ASK FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE
. MISS DAVIES IS WITHHOLDING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. MS REYES
MOVES AND MISTER GIPSON SECONDS
. THIS TOO IS A SUSPENSION OF
THE RULES AND A PROCEDURAL VOTE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ASKING FOR AN I. AND MISS DAVIES
KNOW THIS RACE IS ASKING FOR AYE
VOTE AND MISS DAVIS IS ASKING
FOR A NO. THE.
THIS IS PROCEDURAL. HIS RACE
ASKING FOR NINE MISS DAVIS YOU
KNOW THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
EYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS FIFTEEN
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE. SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND CURRENT MAYOR
OF SAN DIEGO THE HONORABLE TODD
GLORIA IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
MISTER GLORIA.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. SECOND READING FOR CALLING
. SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN NINETY
EIGHT. ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. ON RECONSIDERATION FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
MEMBERS MR COOLEY IS GOING TO BE
TAKING UP. THE JOINT RULES ITEM. THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE ARE
TAKING UP. MR COLLIES S. C. R.
EIGHTY TWO. WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE S. C. R. EIGHTY TWO AND THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY TWO
BY SENATOR ACTIONS RELATIVE TO
THE ADOPTION OF THE JOINT RULES
OF THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
REGULAR SESSION. MISS COOLEY YOU
MAY OPEN. COLLEAGUES EMPLOYEES
OR STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
CHAIR OF THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE TODAY WE BRING BEFORE
U. S. YOU ARE EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATE PRO TEM TONI ATKINS WHICH
IS IN THE COURSE OF OUR ROUTINE
WE PERIODICALLY UPDATE THE RULES
ARM SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY TWO ESTABLISHES WILL
ESTABLISH A JOINT RULES OF THE
TWENTY. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SESSION INCLUDES VARIOUS CHANGES
JOINT RULES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WHEN THEIR LAST ADOPTED
AMONG THE CHANGES ARE A NEW RULE
THAT REQUIRES ANY BILL AMENDING
THE PROTECT APP BASED DRIVERS
AND SERVICES ACT WHICH WAS
ADOPTED BY PROPOSITION TWENTY
TWO- IN TWENTY TWENTY TO BE IN
PRINT FOR TWELVE BUSINESS DAYS
PART OF PASSAGE THIS ONE OF
THOSE RULES WAS EMBODIED IN THIS
OF ITSELF. WE'RE JUST BRING IT
BRING A RULES INCOME FORTY WITH
THAT IT WILL ALSO ALLOW MEMBERS
TO JOIN AUTHOR A BILL FROM THE
OTHER HOUSE WITH WRITTEN
APPROVAL ™THE PRO
SPEAKER- IT DOES NOT EXTEND TO
BECAME THE LEAD AUTHOR OF A BILL
IN THE SENATE BUT YOU CAN BE A
JOINT AUTHORS WITH A SENATOR.
AND IT ALLOWS UP TO EIGHT
MEMBERS TO BE APPOINTED FROM
EACH HOUSE TO THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE SORT
PERMITS EXPANSION OF THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE TO UP TO
FOUR MEMBERS FROM EACH HOUSE OR%
EIGHT MEMBERS WHICH HOUSE. I AM
REMOVED FOR IS RELATED TO WHAT A
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE CAN
CONSIDER AND WHEN THE CONVERSE
REPORT MUST BE SUBMITTED- IT
CLARIFIES THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR ACCREDITED PRESS
REPRESENTS TRIFECTA LONGSTANDING
PRACTICE OF APPLYING TO THE PRO
TEAM AND SPEAKER FOR MEDIA
CREDENTIALS THIS IS STILL DONE
IN CONCERT WITH THE- PRESS.
STATE CAN. REPRESENTS OF THE
PRESS THE FORMER COMMITTEE TO
REVIEW ALL THE APPLICATIONS. IT
PROVIDES THAT THE CHAIRPERSON
JOINT LET'S SAY BUDGET COMMITTEE
IS A SENATOR SELECTED BY THE PRO
TEM. VICE OF THE CHAIRPERSON OF
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE IS TO
BE AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOMINEE BY
THE SPEAKER. IT ALLOWS STANDING
COMMITTEES SUBCOMMITTEES ARE
COVER SCREWS TO HOLD HEARINGS IN
THE SWING SPACE KERN ROOMS IN
ADDITION TO THE STATE CAPITOL.
SAT ALLOWS US TO OPENUP OUR
HEARINGS ACROSS THE WAY THE
CONVENIENCE OF THE PUBLIC AND
MEMBERS. IT INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
MINOR TECHNICAL REVISIONS
INCLUDE REVISING LINES
THROUGHOUT THE JOINT RULES THE
GENERAL NEUTRAL. THE RULES WILL
ENSURE THAT THE SENATE ASEMBLY
OPERATION WILL BE SMOOTH AND
EFFICIENT AS WE CONTINUE OUR
WORK I DO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ON S. YOU ARE
EIGHTY TWO BY PRO TEM ATKINS.
THANK YOU MR COOLEY. SEEING NO
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM. WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THIS S. C. R. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
RESIDE OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
HIGHS FIFTY ONE KNOWS SEVENTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
MR TANG'S SB. ONE NINETEEN ONE
NINETEEN. WITHOUT REFERENCE THE
FILE CORRECT SENATE BILL ONE
NINETEEN BY SERVICE SKINNER AND
ACT LEADING TO THE STATE BUDGET
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL BUDGET
BILL MISTER CHANG YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU THAT'S BECAUSE THE ONE
NINETEEN MAKES TECHNICAL CHANGES
TO THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THE BILL
HAS NO COUGH THE TWO MAJOR
PROVISIONS ARE RE APPROPRIATES
SIXTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET TO COUNTIES FOR THE
REPLACEMENT OF VOTING MACHINES
AND TECHNOLOGY. AND ALSO ALLOWS
FUNDING TO THE COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING FOR STANDARDS IN
TRAINING TO BE TRANSFERABLE
BETWEEN- BETWEEN- FREE SYSTEMS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF IMPLEMENTING
A FEATURE. BUT RIVAL. THANK
MISTAKE MR FONG YOUR RECOGNIZE I
THANK YOU SPEAKER A MEMBERS I
ENFORCE THE RISE IN OPPOSITION
SB ONE NINETEEN SEVEN VERSIONS
OF THE BUDGET WE HAVE HEARD
SEVEN BUDGET BILLS SINCE JUNE OF
LAST YEAR WE ARE THREE MONTHS
FROM THE CONCERT SO DEADLINE TO
PASS NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET AND
WE'RE STILL FIXING AND CHANGING
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. THIS IS
UNHEARD OF AND BEGS THE QUESTION
IS ARE BUDGET PROCESS WORKING
SIGNIFICANT POLICY PROPOSALS DO
NOT BELONG IN A BUDGET BILL IF
THESE CHANGES REALLY ARE
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT WE
WOULD NOT HAVE THIS PIECEMEAL
AND PATCHWORK PROCESS I CANNOT
SUPPORT DIVERTING FUNDING FROM
POLICE OFFICER TRAINING TO
DECERTIFICATION AYE OPPOSED SB
TWO AND I CANNOT SUPPORT TAKING
FUNDING AWAY FROM LOCAL AGENCIES
AT THIS TIME. I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANKS FONG MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. AS CHAIR OF HIGHER
EDUCATION I THINK THAT'S AND
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE HAVE TO VOTE ON
EMERGENCY LEGISLATION SO THAT
STUDENTS CAN ATTEND ONE OF OUR
CAMPUSES. THIS IS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE DESIGN THE MASTER
PLAN ON HIGHER EDUCATION MISTER
MISTER MEDINA IF I COULD ASK YOU
TO WITH WITH OLDER COMMENTS I
BELIEVE THAT IS IN REFERENCE TO
THE UPCOMING. BUDGET ITEM. THANK
YOU SIR. LOOKING FOR OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THIS BUDGET ITEM. SECONDARY
NINE. CLICK LIBERAL. MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF THE.
SB ONE EIGHTEEN AGAIN MISTER
CHANG CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY OF MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY ABILITY
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER CHENEY
MAKE IT OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER S. B. I'M VERY HONORED
TO RISE IN SUPPORT FOR THAT SB
ONE EIGHTEEN SB ONE EIGHTEEN IS
THE RESPONSE TO A COURT CASE
THAT CAME DOWN IN THE FALL OF
LAST YEAR COPYING STUDENT
ENROLLMENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY- THIS
STUDENT ROLE MEANT. HAS BEEN
GROWING OVER THE LAST NUMBER
YEARS PARTLY AT THE DIRECTION OF
THIS BODY THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR. WE HAVE A TWO
MILLION DEGREE SHORTFALL WERE
TWO MEN TO BE SHORT IF WE CANNOT
INCREASE ENROLLMENT INCREASED
CAPACITY AT BERKELEY ALL THE
OTHER UC'S AS WELL AS ALL THE
CSU THAT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SO AS A FOCUS OF THIS VERY BODY
WE'VE BEEN PUSHING. ALL THE
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
I MEAN SURE THAT WE CAN KEEP
COLLEGE AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE. FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA
WHO WANTS IT. THIS WAS A MAJOR
BLOW TO THE- THAT MOVE INTO THAT
MISSION- WE HAD A ACTIVISTS
JUDGE WHO HANDED DOWN A VERY
DRACONIAN. A PROPOSAL. OKAY
BURGER CO DECISION
UNFORTUNATELY. WHEN THE APPEALS
COURT DID NOT STATE THE
DECISION. FIVE THOUSAND
POTENTIAL ADMITS WHO WERE
WAITING TO BE ADMITTED TO
BERKELEY. WE'RE GONNA BE
POTENTIALLY GIVEN REJECTION
LETTERS OR AFTER DEFERRED TO THE
SPRING OR ASKED TO TAKE THEIR
COURSES ONLINE. IT AS SOMEBODY
WHO CAN PERSONALLY ATTEST TO.
HOW UC BERKELEY CAN CHANGE
LIVES. I DON'T THINK THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE LET THAT HAPPEN THE
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
PENALIZED FOR THE UNIVERSITY'S
MISTAKES A COUPLE MISTAKES
UNIVERSITY MADE. IN TERMS OF NOT
ADEQUATELY PROJECTING ENROLLMENT
IN THEIR LONG RANGE CAMPUS
DEVELOPMENT PLAN. THEY ALSO MADE
A MISTAKE OF NOT ASKING FOR A
STAY WHEN THE EARLY DECISION
CAME DOWN. I DON'T THINK FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS SHOULD REALLY
PAY THE PRICE FOR A BAD YOUR
CREDIT DECISIONS AND A VERY.
POOR LAWYER WHO MADE A
DISPOSITION ARE NOT REALLY DOING
HIS OR HER JOB. AND SO TODAY WE
ARE RISING TO DO A COUPLE THINGS
ONE IS TO ENSURE THAT. WE TALK
ABOUT ANY UNIVERSITY COLLEGE AS
LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLAN THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CAMPUS
ENROLLMENT WILL TALK ABOUT
CAMPUS POPULATION NOT TO STUDENT
ENROLLMENT. CAMPUS POPULATION
INCLUDES STUDENTS FACULTY AS
WELL AS STAFF ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE AT A PARTICULAR UNIVERSITY
THAT DID NOT A DEFINITION IS
VERY ACCURATE AND REFLECTIVE OF
THE IMPACT OF THE INVOLVEMENT OF
THAT PARTICULAR CITY AND WHAT'S
GOING ON. ALSO WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE DRACONIAN JUDGE CAN'T
JUST HAND DOWN A DECISION
WITHOUT GIVING IT A UNIVERSITY
OR COLLEGE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REMEDY IT. SO IF THE LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN IS SOMETHING TO
PORT DOES NOT LIKE THAT WORK CAN
ASK THE UNIVERSITY TO ADDRESS IT
AND COME BACK IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AND THEN AFTER THAT. COULD DO
SOMETHING BUT ONLY INTEL ONLY
ALLOWING THE ONLY TO THE ALLOW
THE UNIVERSITY TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THEIR LONG RICH ABOUT THE
PLAN THIS IS A VERY SURGICAL
APPROACH TO THIS PARTICULAR
DECISION. I DON'T THINK IT HAS
LONG TERM ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT I
THINK IT REALLY. ACCURATELY
DESCRIBES WHAT A LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN SHOULD BE AS
WELL AS LIMITING THE A SOLUTION
TO COURT COULD PRESCRIBE WITHOUT
I SUSPECT WE ASK. FOR YOUR VOTE
ON SB ONE EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU
MISTER THIS SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY
TO ADD MY VOICE OF SUPPORT FOR
S. B. ONE ONE ONE EIGHT. WE
SHOULD ALL AGREE ON THE NEED TO
MAKE ROOM FOR MORE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AT OUR FINEST PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES. THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. I AM NOT AT ALL A
SUPPORTER OF CREATING SEQUEL
EXEMPTIONS I AM NOT A PROPONENT.
OF GETTING ENACTED IS MADE
CALIFORNIA A LEADER IN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL INNOVATION. WE ACT
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN RECENTLY
THE MISGUIDED APPLICATION OF AN
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW TO STUDENT
ENROLLMENT. THE ACTUAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT IS NOT.
FROM HOW MANY STUDENTS WE LEAD
IN IT A RESULT IS THE RESULT OF
THE TOTAL CAMPUS POPULATION. AND
HOW THAT AFFECTS ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. WE MUST ACT TODAY IN A
CAUTIOUS FASHION. TO MAKE SURE
THE UNIVERSITY COULD ADMIT
DESERVING APPLICANTS. THIS YEAR.
THE UC ADMINISTRATION MUST ACT
TODAY AND IN THE FUTURE THE PLAN
APPROPRIATELY FOR THE IMPACTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CAMPUS
POPULATION. UNIVERSITIES REMAIN
COVERED BY SYKORA AND THEY
SHOULD BE. FOR THE SAKE OF
TODAY'S APPLICANTS WHO REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA'S OUR FUTURE I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB ONE
EIGHTY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER MR
FONG. I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF
THE BEST A PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS IN THE COUNTRY
AND WE CANNOT LET A COSTLY
LAWSUIT USING A LAW THAT IS IN
DESPERATE NEED OF REFORM STIFEL
THE EDUCATIONAL DREAMS ARE OUR
BEST AND BRIGHTEST STUDENTS IN
OUR STATE. WE A LEGISLATORS
MUST CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEIR
THESE STUDENTS IN THEIR PURSUIT
OF THEIR DREAMS THIS BILL
CREATES THOUGH ANOTHER EXEMPTION
FROM THE STATE'S EQUAL LAW TO
ALLOW MORE STUDENTS TO ATTEND
WORLD CLASS UNIVERSITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT CAN BE
FOUND IN DIVISION THIRTEEN OF
THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE THIS
LAW REQUIRES ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORTS FOR A VARIETY OF
PROJECTS INCLUDING CHANGES IN
ENROLLMENT LEVEL LEVELS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION THIS BILL
AMENDS THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE
BY CARVING OUT CHANGES IN ROMAN
LEVELS FROM ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT REQUIREMENTS. WE ARE
MAKING NEEDED MODIFICATIONS TO
SEE WHAT. AND WE SHOULD BE
MODIFYING SYKORA FOR OTHER
NECESSARY PROJECTS. WELL WE
AREN'T CHANGING ACTUAL
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS WE ARE
CHANGING WHAT THEY APPLY TO.
THIS LAST MINUTE BILL HOWEVER
HIGHLIGHTS THE FACT THAT SEQUEL
IS DATED AND BROKEN. THE SEQUEL
LAW WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY OVER A HALF A CENTURY
AGO. OUR STATE WAS DIFFERENT OUR
NEEDS WERE DIFFERENT OUR STATE
IS NOW DEFINED BY CRISIS AFTER
CRISIS FROM HOMELESSNESS TO ONE
OF OUR PREVENTION. THE
TRANSPORTATION A SUPPLY CHAIN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO WATER STORAGE
AND TO HOUSING. BUT OVER THE
YEARS SEQUEL HAS BEEN ABUSED
THROUGH LITIGATION. TO STOP
PROJECTS THAT SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY AND ADDRESS THESE
CRISES. OFTENTIMES THE REASONS
TO STOP THE PROJECTS. HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT HAVE BEEN USED
BY GROUPS WITH NARROW AGENDAS TO
PURSUE FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS AS WE
SEE RIGHT NOW. IN KERN COUNTY
NEED HIGHWAY SAFETY PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN DELAYED DRIVING UP
COSTS AND EXPENSES A PRECIOUS
TAX DOLLARS. NEEDED HOUSING
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
FROM THE TOP OF THE STATE TO THE
BAY AREA. THROUGH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND DOWN TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THESE PROJECTS BEEN
HELD UP BY LAWSUITS USING
SEQUEL. HOUSING THAT WOULD HELP
EASE THE STATE'S HOUSING AND
AFFORDABLE FOR ABILITY CRISIS.
WE NOW SEE ANOTHER SEQUEL
LAWSUIT AGAINST UC BERKELEY THAT
HAS LED TO UNFORTUNATE REAL
WORLD CONSEQUENCES IMPACTING THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE HIGHER
EDUCATION. TO OUR STUDENTS. WELL
THIS BILL AS NECESSARY IT
FOLLOWS A LONG LINE OF SECRET
CHANGES THAT ONLY HIGHLIGHTS THE
NEED FOR A BROAD BASED REFORM OF
THIS AW. A GROWING CONSENSUS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR SEEK
REFORM. BUT THE QUESTION REMAINS
IS THERE THE POLITICAL WILL TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN. WHERE WILL OUR
STATE. CONTINUE TO BE PARALYZED
BY CIVIL LAWSUITS THAT WILL
PREVENT NEEDED IMPROVEMENTS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES FROM TAKING
PLACE. THIS BILL CORRECTS A
CLEAR ABUSE OF SEQUEL AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY OF SB ONE
EIGHTEEN BUT MEMBERS WE ALL KNOW
THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE.
REFORM SEQUEL. THANK WHICH FONG
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
. LET ME START BY THANKING OUR
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND OUR SPEAKERS OF FOR THIS
QUICK RESPONSE TO SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND THAT EXPLAIN
WHY JUMPED UP TOO SOON TO SPEAK
ON THIS MEASURE. WHAT IS CHAIR
OF HIGHER EDUCATION I THINK THAT
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE HAVE TO VOTE ON THIS
EMERGENCY LEGISLATION TODAY SO
THAT STUDENTS CAN ATTEND ONE OF
OUR CAMPUSES. THIS IS THE STATE
THE DESIGN THE MASTER PLAN WHOSE
PRESIDENT CLARK KERR DIRECTED
THE TOP PUBLIC UNIVERSITY IN THE
COUNTRY PERHAPS EVEN IN THE
WORLD. ALTHOUGH I ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. I AM
DISAPPOINTED THAT BLENDED
STUDENTS BECOME PARIAHS OR
EYESORES THEY WERE NO LONGER
WELCOME IN OUR COMMUNITIES IN
THE PAST FEW WEEKS WE HAVE
FOLLOWED THE NEWS AROUND THE
CITIZEN GROUP. IN THE CITY OF
BERKELEY AND THE COURT RULING
AGAINST THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. TO SAY THAT STUDENTS
PRESENT AS WE HEARD THIS MORNING
IS A THREAT EVEN AN
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT IS SIMPLY
WRONG. HOWEVER THIS ISSUE IS NOT
JUST ABOUT ONE CITY OR ONE
CITIZEN GROUP OR EVEN ONE CAMPUS
IS A GREATER PROBLEM. NOT JUST
THE ANIMOSITY TOWARDS STUDENTS
BUT THE BARRIERS TO PURSUING
HIGHER EDUCATION. THIS TYPE OF
REACTIONARY ATTITUDE STEMS FROM
A DEEP IGNORANCE OF THE BENEFITS
OF UNIVERSITIES. TO THE
COMMUNITIES AND BECAUSE OF THAT
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
EIGHTEEN AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA. AND MR MCCARTY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO WANT TO- SUPPORT
THIS ITEM TODAY YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE THE SWIFT ACTION THAT
OUR LEGISLATURE TOOK IN RESPONSE
TO THIS REVIEW REALLY DANGEROUS
DECISION THIS WOULD HAVE SHUT
THE DOORS OF COLLEGE EDUCATION
FOR THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
AND WE KNOW AND I SAY THIS ALL
TIME WE GO BACK HOME AND TALK TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS ABOUT THE
BUDGET WE DO SOME OF THE MOST%
POPULAR THINGS THAT WE DO OUR
TALKING ABOUT INCREASING ACCESS
TO THE UNIVERSITY. WHY DOES IT
MATTER AS OUR BUDGET CHAIR
STATED WE NEED THIS FOR OUR
ECONOMY OUR OUR ECONOMY REQUIRES
MORE COLLEGE GRADUATES WE KNOW
THAT COLLEGE IS THE TICKET TO
THE MIDDLE CLASS SO WE STAND
HERE TODAY WITH THE STRATEGIC
FIX TO THE SEQUEL PROCESS
SOMEONE TO REFORM THIS WHOLE
BILL IN SEQUENCE SO FORTH AND GO
ABOUT IT IN A SEPARATE WAY THIS
IS MAKING SURE WE PROTECT THE
INTERESTS OF OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS OUR STATE AND OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND NOT LET- NIMBYS
SHUT THE DOORS OF COLLEGE FOR
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WANT
TO ADVANCE THEIR LIVES. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP FOR CALIFORNIA
AND MAKE SURE WE PROTECT NOT
ONLY THIS UNIVERSITY BUT OTHER
COLLEGE CAMPUSES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO KEEP ENROLLING
STUDENTS TODAY AND TOMORROW AND
LASTLY WE DO KNOW THAT THE BIG
ISSUE THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM
SIGN UP HOUSING WE NEED MORE
HOUSING ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND AT
COLLEGE CAMPUSES- WE'RE DOING SO
IN THIS BUDGET. THAT WE JUST
PASSED IN JUNE WE'RE DOING SO IN
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET AS WELL AND I
WILL NOTE THAT SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SAYING WE
SHOULDN'T GROW SO MUCH
UNIVERSITIES YOU KNOW ALSO THE
OPPOSED NEW HOUSING AT THE SAME
UNIVERSITIES SO YOU CAN'T HAVE
IT BOTH WAYS SO THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE ACTION TODAY AND
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK OUR BUDGET
CHAIR OUR SPEAKER AND ARE
FRANKLY OUR STAFF IN THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WE COMING UP WITH A
SWIFT RESPONSE TO ALLOW THE
STUDENTS TO ENROLL AND FULLY
ENROLL STUDENTS AT UC BERKELEY.
THIS FALL THANK YOU. THANK REST
REGARDING MR MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I RISE AS A PROUD CAL BEAR IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE BUT- YOU
KNOW AND I WANT TO CONGRATULATE
MY FORMER CLASSMATE AND FROM CAL
AND FOR SUPPORTING THOSE CAL
CALORIES TODAY- AND MAKING SURE
THAT- THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS ARE
NOT DENIED YOU KNOW THEIR DREAM
AFTER ALL THE HARD WORK AND ALL
THE ANXIETY THAT WE KNOW THAT
OUR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS HAVE TO
GO THROUGH. YOU KNOW TO WORK
HARD TO GET INTO CAL BUT I WANT
TO- MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T LOSE
SIGHT OF THE BIGGER ISSUE WHICH
IS THAT. YOU KNOW OUR UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA HAS NOT TO JUST
KEPT UP WITH THE CAPACITY. TO
AND TO MEET THE DEMAND THE EVER
INCREASING DEMAND ESPECIALLY TO
GET INTO- IT THE MOST POPULAR-
CAMPUSES LIKE LIKE BERKELEY. AND
YOU KNOW I WANT TO. CONTINUE TO
URGE. OUR BUDGET CHAIR AND ARE
BUDGET SUB TO CHAIR AND ALL OF
OUR EFFORTS TO CONTINUE TO PUSH
ON WHAT I THINK SHOULD BE A NO
BRAINER FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHICH IS THAT WE KEEP PUSHING.
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA TO
ADMIT MORE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS-
INTO- BERKELEY AND ALL OUR OTHER
UC CAMPUSES- YOU KNOW EVEN AT
THE EXPENSE OF CUTTING DOWN ON
OUT OF STATE AND INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS. THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA LAST TIME I CHECKED
IS STILL THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IT SHOULD BE SERVING
FIRST AND FOREMOST CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND I HOPE THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO PUSH IN THAT EFFORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI THREE OF US. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BILL IS CLEARLY
PUTTING THE INTEREST OF STUDENTS
FIRST. WE ALL KNOW ATTENDING UC
BERKELEY CHANGES LIVES FOR MANY
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY ARE FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS. AND I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE SOUTH
BAY. ARE THEY SHOULD BE
CALIFORNIANS- THAT WE PRIORITIZE
TO ADMIT TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY. THANKS TO
OUR BUDGET CHAIR AND OUR SPEAKER
WERE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING TODAY
TO MAKE SURE THAT NO ONE THAT
WAS GOING TO BE ADMITTED. I WILL
WILL GET A THE BAD IT MAIL
PIECE- UNFORTUNATELY A REJECTION
I SHOULD SAY. BUT AS OUR BUDGET
CHAIR MENTIONED MISTAKES WERE
MADE BY UC BERKELEY I AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY THAT'S WHY
W'RE RUSHING THIS THROUGH.
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT AFFECTS
STUDENTS BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE
NOT GOING THROUGH THE FULL
POLICY PROCESS AND PUBLIC REVIEW
THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS SHOULD-
I AM IN SUPPORT BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT ANY STUDENT- TO MISS OUT ON
THIS OPPORTUNITY. OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S PREMIER PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY BUT IN THE FUTURE I
HOPE THAT. OTHER UNIVERSITIES
OTHER PROJECTS DON'T MAKE THE
SAME MISTAKES- TO LEAD US AGAIN
TO RUSH THROUGH THIS POLICY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS REQUEST
AND MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO JOIN THE
COURSE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
EIGHTEEN. THIS IS A BILL THAT
IS. SOMEWHAT PERSONAL FOR ME
HAVING BEEN BORN IN THE CITY OF
BERKELEY THAT'S A CITY THAT'S
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART.
AND ALSO BEING A PROUD GRADUATE
OF UC BERKELEY I CAN SEE BOTH
SIDES OF. THE ISSUE HERE BUT I
THINK THAT THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
THE RIGHT SOLUTION AND I WANT TO
FIRST CONGRATULATE AND APPLAUD
OUR BUDGET CHAIR IN OUR SPEAKER
AND ALL THE LEADERSHIP. FOR
THEIR SWIFT ACTION HERE I THINK
THERE ARE THOSE WHO DOUBTED THAT
THE LEGISLATOR SURE COULDN'T
MOVE QUICKLY ENOUGH TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE ON SUCH A SHORT FUSE
AND SO I WANT TO EXTEND. THANKS
AND AN APPRECIATION FOR ALL OF
THE FOLKS WHO ARE AT THE CENTER
OF THIS CONVERSATION AND I THINK
I'VE COME UP. WITH A REALLY
IMPORTANT ANSWERED ALL THIS.
ALSO HOPE THAT THIS THIS ACTION
THAT WE ARE TAKING TODAY SENDS A
MESSAGE NOT JUST TO THE BERKELEY
COMMUNITY BUT TO COMMUNITIES AND
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
AROUND THE STATE THIS
LEGISLATURE IS COMMITTED TO
OPENING DOORS OF OPPORTUNITY.
NOT CLOSING THEM AND WE WILL
TAKE WHATEVER ACTION IS
NECESSARY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CROWN JEWELS OF OUR PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM THE
INSTITUTIONS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THAT STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO
ATTEND THOSE UNIVERSITIES TO
RECEIVE A WORLD CLASS
OPPORTUNITY. TO GO INTO MOVE
THEIR FAMILIES INTO THE MIDDLE
CLASS AND TO CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH
TO OUR STATE AND I REALLY DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS TODAY IS ABOUT
FIXING BERKELEY. BUT HE'S ALSO
ABOUT SENDING A MESSAGE THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE WILL DO WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DOORS OF HIGHER EDUCATION AND
OPPORTUNITY REMAIN OPEN. AND
ALSO WANT TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS OF OUR BUDGET
SUB CHAIR FROM SACRAMENTO. THIS
IS ALSO ABOUT HOUSING IN THIS IS
ANOTHER REMINDER WHEREVER WE
LOOK WE SEE OUR HOUSING CRISIS
MANIFESTED ITSELF IN IT SO MANY
ISSUES WHEN WE START TO LOOK AT
THEM THEY SEEM TO BE ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE. AND THEN AS WE
PEEL BACK THE LAYERS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT OUR HOUSING
CRISIS IS AT THE ROOT OF THEM.
SO WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO ARE
INVOLVEDIN THIS WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE A BIPARTISAN STRONG
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS GABRIEL AND HIS WICKS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I RISE
AND OBVIOUS SUPPORT. OF THIS AND
I WANT TO THANK OUR BUDGET
SHARE. THE SPEAKER- OTHER FOLKS
TO WORK ON THIS OUR GREAT
SENATOR FROM BERKELEY WHO. SPENT
A LOT OF TIME ON THIS AS WELL. I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
AND THINK IT'S AN OBVIOUS
NECESSARY STEP. FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS SHOULDN'T HAVE TO PAY
THE PRICE FOR MISGUIDED
NIMBYISM. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
LAWSUIT WAS ABOUT. THOSE ARE
KIDS WHO OF MANY THEM SPEND OUR
LIFE. TRYING TO GET INTO THIS
UNIVERSE YOU ARE THE BEST
UNIVERSITY UNIVERSITIES. IN THE
WORLD. AND THE THOUGHT THAT THEY
WOULD BE DENIED. BECAUSE OF
NIMBYS WHO DON'T WANT TO. HAVE
THEM IN OUR COMMUNITY AND MY
COMMUNITY THE COMMUNITY I
REPRESENT. IS APPALLING. AND THE
SAME FOLKS THAT BROUGHT FORTH
THIS LAWSUIT TO SUE THE
UNIVERSITY FOR NOT PROVIDING
ENOUGH HOUSING. ACTUALLY FIGHT.
THE YOU SEE WHEN THEY WANT TO
BUILD THAT HOUSING. SO LET'S NOT
FORGET WHAT DROVE THIS LAWSUIT
AND LET'S ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
WE- AS A BODY ACT WHEN IT IS
TIME FOR US TO VOTE FOR HOUSING
PRODUCTION BILLS. WE GET THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT RIGHT IN
THIS BODY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE ENOUGH HOUSING. NOT JUST
FOR STUDENTS BUT FOR WORKING
CLASS FOLKS AND OUR NURSES AND
ORDERLIES DOES AND OUR COPS AND
OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND EVERYONE
ELSE RIGHT NOW WHO IS TRAVELING
FAR TOO LONG TO COMMUTE TO
THEIR- JOBS WHO ARE. WHO ARE ON
THE VERGE OF BEING KICKED OUT OF
THEIR APARTMENTS WE GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE CHANGE HERE.
SO I ASK YOU ALL TO THINK ABOUT
THIS AS YOU MOVE FORWARD AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF EXCITING HOUSING
BILLS COMING OUT OF THIS BODY.
THAT THE FRUSTRATION THAT YOU'VE
SEEN FROM THIS LAWSUIT. IS SHE
TOLD THE VOTING YES ON HOUSING
PRODUCTION BILLS. I STRONGLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS WICKS SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM MR TANG
YOU MAY CLOSE. IT'S BECAUSE WE
JUST THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THIS VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION WE
ALSO JUST THANK- THE SENATE MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR SKINNER AS
WELL AS SENATE PRO TEM REALLY
FOR THEIR- WORK IT REALLY TOOK A
LOT OF TEAMWORK TO REALLY GET
THIS. BILL DONE IN SUCH A QUICK
IN TIMELY FASHION ALSO WANTED TO
THANK THE CHAIRS OF OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE ARE HOUSING
COMMITTEE ARE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THEY AND THEIR STAFFS
WERE INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN
REALLY CRAFTING AND THINKING
THROUGH. THIS PARTICULAR
SOLUTION ALSO WANT TO THANKTHE
SPEAKER STOP AS WELL AS OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF WHO
REALLY WORKED MANY MANY HOURS TO
MAKE SURE WE GOT THIS BILL DONE.
VERY VERY QUICKLY AGAIN IF THE
THINK YOU'VE HEARD WHAT EVERYONE
SAID THIS IS A TIME. TO JUST
HAPPEN ASSIST A GROUP OF
STUDENTS AT THE UNIVERSITY BUT
REALLY OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES REMAIN
OPEN AND AFFORDABLE TO ALL AT
THE SAME TIME ENSURE THAT WE
KEEP A LONG VIEW AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE STILL FOCUSED ON.
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN PROVIDE IN
A UNIQUE TO THESE COMMUNITIES
EACH OF THESE NEIGHBORHOODS AS
WEAK UP THE NUMBERS OF
ENROLLMENT ACROSS THE VERY STATE
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO SERVE SO
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY AS RIVAL.
ON SB ONE ONE EIGHT. AND WITH
CLERK LEVEL ROLE. THESE ARE THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRABLE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
HAS YOUR PASSES WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE AS WELL AS
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE ON S. C. R. EIGHTY TWO.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
THERE IS WHERE MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MR KILEY FOR PURPOSE
SIR. I'D LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION.
I MOVE TO SUSPEND THE RULES AS
WE'VE DONE MULTIPLE TIMES TODAY
ALREADY TO TAKE OUT MY BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
THIS WILL SUSPEND THE STATE GAS
TAX IMMEDIATELY AND SAVE
CALIFORNIANS FIFTY CENTS A
GALLON. THAT MOTION REQUIRES A
SECOND SECONDED BY MS DAVIS
MEMBERS THIS MOTION IS NOT
DEBATABLE. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES TO SUSPEND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL THREE READINGS
REQUIREMENTS. ON AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT AND THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. CLARK WELL OPEN
ROOM. NEVER CEASES PROCEDURAL
MISTER KILEY IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND IS RACES ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE MISTER KILEY IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND MS RACES
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. ON THE
SUSPENSION. OF THE CONSTITUTION
. OKAY. THE GAME IS BECAUSE HAS
FOR NINE MINUTES REYES AND NO.
IT'S TWO THIRDS VOTE REQUIREMENT.
AND A. CLARK WELL. CLOSE RURAL.
HIS EIGHTEEN KNOWS FORTY. THAT
MOTION FAILS. ON THE.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I
UNDERSTAND THAT MR BLOOM HAS
BECOME A GRANDFATHER TODAY
CONGRATULATIONS MISTER BLOOM.
THANK YOU FOR THE GOOD NEWS.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE ON THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE. SAM
APARTMENT FILE ITEM NUMBERS
THREE. FOUR AND FIVE PASS AND
RETAIN.
MEMBERS YOU MAY TAKE YOUR BLOOM
HUGS OFF THE GREEN CARPET AT
THIS TIME. MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX ACR ONE FIFTY
FIVE BY MISS AGUILAR CURRY THE
CLERK WILL READ. THE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY RELATIVE TO FAMILY
PHYSICIAN WEEK. MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M HONORED
TODAY TO PRESENT ACR ONE FIFTY
FIVE WHICH RECOGNIZES MARCH
THIRTEENTH THROUGH MARCH
NINETEENTH AS FAMILY PHYSICIAN
WEEK AND HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
TO THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. AND
TOWARD COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
THOSE IN RURAL AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THE ONLY POSITIONS
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY CARE TO
EVERYONE FROM OUR YOUNGEST TO
OUR ELDEST THEY HAVE BEEN AT THE
FRONT LINE FOR THIS ENTIRE
PANDEMIC. PANDEMIC SEES MAKING
SURE OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
VACCINATED AND HAVE ACCESS TO
ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THEY HAVE BOTH REVOLUTIONIZE
CARE DELIVERY THROUGH INTEGRATED
COORDINATED AND TEAM BASED CARE
AND REDUCE HEALTHCARE COSTS BY
FOCUSING ON PREVENTIVE CARE AND
KEEPING PATIENTS HEALTHY. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING THEM
TODAY AND LET'S CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE WITH THEM AS THEY
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND CREATE A MORE
EQUITABLE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM FOR
ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I WOULD-LIKE THE ROLE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. MEMBERS WE WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ACTOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR
ONE FIFTY FIVE CLICK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. SEEING NO DEBATE. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE MOTIVES ARE
TO VOTE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY ONE CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL NOW
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. OF THOSE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE WILL
NOW HAVE OUR GUESTS IN THE
GALLERY. RECOGNIZED TO MARK
FAMILY PHYSICIAN WEEK ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ID OR CURRY
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM SEVEN ACR ONE FIFTY
SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
AND OTHERS RELATIVES IRISH
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. MISTER
MELANIE MILTON. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. PROUD TO RISE 2% ACR
ONE FIFTY SIX. WHICH DESIGNATES
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS IRISH
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH IN HONOR
OF THE MULTITUDE OF
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT IRISH
AMERICANS HAVE MADE TO THE
COUNTRY AND THE STATE. MILLIONS
OF IRISH PEOPLE FACE WAS SEVERE
HARDSHIP. DUE TO FAMINE AND
POVERTY IN THEIR NATION
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL CENTURIES
IN SEARCH OF A MORE PROMISING
FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THE JOURNEY TO AMERICA
WAS NOT PAVED WITH GOLD. LIKE
MANY IMMIGRANTS THE AVERAGE
SPIRIT OF DETERMINATION
PERSEVERANCE AND GRIT PREVAILED
AGAINST DANGEROUS SEASON DEADLY
CONDITIONS WITH THEIR HEARTS SET
ON THE HORIZON. OUR KIDS
INITIALLY SUFFER PREJUDICE AND
DISCRIMINATION UPON FIRST
ARRIVING IN THE UNITED STATES AS
THE YEARS WENT ON IRISH
AMERICANS BECAME DEEPLY
INTEGRATED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND MADE NUMEROUS CONTRIBUTIONS
AT ALL ASPECTS OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY AND CULTURE- CAN TO
BLADE VITAL ROLES IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE U. S. NINE
IRISH MERICANS WERE SIGNERS OF
THE DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE.
AND TWENTY TWO PRESIDENTS OF THE
UNITED STATES HAVE BEEN OF IRISH
HERITAGE INCLUDING JOHN F.
KENNEDY RONALD REAGAN BILL
CLINTON AND BARACK OBAMA. MANY
PEOPLE OF IRISH DESCENT HAVE
CONTRIBUTED A GREAT MOVEMENTS
THAT HELPED SHAPE OUR COUNTRY
AND ITS ROLE IN THE WORLD
INCLUDING MOTHER JONES LABOR
ACTIVIST. LUCY BURNS ACTIVISTS
IN THE WOMEN'S MOVEMENT AND
SENATOR GEORGE MITCHELL
NEGOTIATOR OF THE IRISH PEACE
ACCORDS. IRISH AMERICANS HAVE
ALSO PLAYED A MAJOR ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA POLITICS IS
GOVERNOR'S LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
CITY MAYORS AND OTHER PUBLIC
OFFICIALS WHO WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO BUILD CALIFORNIA. TO THE
STATE THAT IT IS TODAY. TODAY
OVER THIRTY FOUR MILLION
AMERICANS CLAIM IRISH HERITAGE
AND THEY CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE.
TO THE AMERICAN IN CALIFORNIA
POLITICAL. CULTURE ECONOMY AND
THE BROADER CULTURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTER ASSET THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION AS A
AS A MEMBER OF THE IRISH
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS- AND AS A
DESCENDANT OF ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE. WHO LEFT IRELAND DURING
THE FAMINE AND CAME TO AMERICA-
FOR OPPORTUNITY AND FREEDOM. AND
PERHAPS YOU KNOW THE IRISH KNOW
A LOT ABOUT THIS BECAUSE LIKE
FAR TOO MANY PEOPLE IN OUR WORLD
THEY EXPERIENCE DEPRESSION AND
THE DEPRIVATION OF FREEDOM AND
OPPORTUNITY. YEAH I WAS I WAS
ABLE TO TRAVEL BACK TO IRELAND-
HERE RECENTLY I LEARNED MORE OF
THE HISTORY OF WHAT MY FAMILY
UNDER. YOU KNOW THAT MY ANCESTOR
- BECAUSE OF HIS FAITH BECAUSE
OF HIS RELIGION WAS NOT ABLE TO
OWN LAND- AND BECAUSE OF THAT.
HE LEFT THAT COUNTRY INNS IN IN
SEARCH OF THAT OPPORTUNITY AND
TO GET AWAY FROM THE OPPRESSION
THAT WITH THE WAS OCCURRING IN
THE COUNTRY AT THAT TIME UNDER
BRITISH RULE- AND WHAT HE FOUND
HEARING CALIFORNIA ALTERNATELY
ARRIVING HERE WITH HIS SEVEN
CHILDREN. CHARLES GALLAGHER WAS
OPPORTUNITY AND THE OPPORTUNITY
FINALLY OWN THAT FIRST PIECE OF
LAND- TO FARM AND TO PROVIDE FOR
HIS FAMILY- AND THIS GREAT STATE
AS IT HAS BEEN FOR SO MANY
ACROSS THIS WORLD. GAVE HIM THAT
OPPORTUNITY. AND THAT IS WHAT I
THINK WE FIVE FOR EVERY DAY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THIS OF IN THIS
VERY LEGISLATURE. BUT IN
IRELAND. THEY FOUGHT FOR THEIR
REPUBLIC AND THEY EARNED IT. AND
THEY BROUGHT FRIEDMAN
OPPORTUNITY AND NOW IN THAT
GREAT COUNTRY THERE IS SO MUCH
OF THAT. AND THEY HAVE FORGED
GREAT RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR
STATE. AND IT BECOME LEADERS AND
SO MANY DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES. IN
AGTECH IN PHARMACEUTICALS. WITH
THAT FREEDOM THEY CONTINUE TO BE
A BECOME A BEACON FOR THE WORLD
IN FACT SPEAKING WITH MINISTER
MCGRATH EARLIER BEFORE THIS
SESSION THEY ARE OPEN UP THEIR
DOORS TO REFUGEES FROM UKRAINE.
ARE FROM THOSE VERY SAME PEOPLE
WHO ARE FIGHTING RIGHT NOW. THEY
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS THEY'RE
FIGHTING RIGHT NOW FOR THAT
FREEDOM THAT SAME FREEDOM AND
OPPORTUNITY. SO THE PARTNERSHIP
THAT WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD. BETWEEN
AMERICA AND IRELAND AND BEING
THOSE FIGHTERS BEING THOSE.
WE'RE ALL FIGHTING IRISHMAN IF
YOU WILL- FIGHTING FOR THAT VERY
FREEDOM AND OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
IS I THINK SOMETHING THEIR- IS
VERY SPECIAL ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE IRISH HERE IN AMERICA- AND
TO STAND FOR THOSE THINGS FOR
ALL PEOPLE IN OUR WORLD. THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND I ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS RESOLUTION
TODAY. THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER MR
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
A CA ONE FIFTY SIX AND AS ALWAYS
A HISTORY LESSON. SO THE IRISH
IN OUR WAR FOR INDEPENDENCE
FOUGHT AGAINST KING GEORGE AND
THEY WERE VERY HAPPY TO FIGHT
AGAINST THE BRITISH BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE DONE FOR
HUNDREDS OF YEARS. NOW IN THE
CIVIL WAR IT WAS INTERESTING
THAT THE IRISH WERE STILL
IMMIGRATING TO THE UNITED STATES
BY THE THOUSANDS AND MANY TIMES
WHEN THE SHIP PULLED IN THE
BOSTON. THE IRISH WE GO STRAIGHT
FROM THE SHIP. TO THE CIVIL WAR
REGIMENTS AND THE IRISH BRIGADE
WAS BASICALLY WIPED OUT FOUR
TIMES IN THE CIVIL WAR. AND THEY
NEVER LACK FOR VOLUNTEERS THE
IRISH OF FOUGHT FOR AMERICA. FOR
TWO HUNDRED PLUS YEARS. WORLD
WAR ONE THE SIXTY NINTH IRISH.
THE VISION. ONCE AGAIN HAD ONE
OF THE HIGHEST CASUALTY RATES IN
WORLD WAR ONE AND THEY FOUGHT
THEY FOUGHT IN A ONE. SO THE
IRISH ARE KNOWN AS THE FIGHTING
IRISH. AND YOU KNOW WHAT AS LONG
AS THEY'RE FIGHTING FOR US I
LOVE THEM THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE AS A PROUD MEMBER
OF THE IRISH CAUCUS MY DAD WAS
BORN IN DONEGAL IRELAND AND CAME
FROM BALLYSHANNON ONE DAY I'D
LOVE TO GO BACK THERE- YOU KNOW
GROWING UP IN AN IRISH FAMILY
IT'S ALL ABOUT DANNY BOY IN THE
IRISH ROVERS AND MY AUNT AND
UNCLE PLAYING THE ACCORDION.
ANNA JUST LOVE THAT THE TIME IN
MY LIFE MY DAD YOU KNOW WHEN THE
FAMILY COME OVER THEY LEFT THE
FARM BEHIND TO A NEW LIFE OVER
HERE IN THIS COUNTRY- YOU KNOW
HE HAD SIX BROTHERS AND SISTERS
SO WE HAD A BIG FAMILY IN THAT
WAY. BUT YOU KNOW THEY FACE
DISCRIMINATION WE REMEMBER IRISH
NEED NOT APPLY BACK IN THOSE
DAYS- YOU KNOW SO IS A TOUGH
LIFE AND YOU KNOW THEY DID
WHATEVER THEY COULD TO MAKE A
LIVING BUT- YOU KNOW MY DAD
SERVED IN WORLD WAR TWO ACTUALLY
WITH A GREEN CARD AND IT TOOK A
LONG TIME FOR HIM TO BECOME A
CITIZEN ACTUALLY AFTER YOU CAME
OUT FROM THE WAR. HE APPLIED- AT
THE METRIC METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION IN NEW YORK TO WORK
IN THE TRAINS THE CONDUCTOR BUT
THEY TOLD ME WASN'T A CITIZEN ON
WASN'T ALLOWED TO APPLY EVEN
THOUGH HE DID GET HIS
CITIZENSHIP WHILE SERVING IN THE
U. S. ARMY. I ALWAYS SAY THAT I
LEARN THE LOVE FOR MY COUNTRY
FROM MY IMMIGRANT PARENTS AND-
IT MEANS A LOT THAT THEY CAME
HERE AND LOVE THIS COUNTRY IN
ONE DAY AS I SAID I'D LOVE TO GO
BACK TO THE OLD SIDE. THANKS
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK MUST MELANIE MAY CLOSE
. THINK ABOUT CHARGES LIKE THIS
I THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
COMMENTS SAID THIS WILL BE THE
LAST OPPORTUNITY HAVE TO PRESENT
THIS RESOLUTION ON THIS FLOOR I
LIKE TO THINK MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER FROM COUNTY DERRY A
FARMER WHO CAME TO AMERICA FOR A
BETTER LIFE. ON BECAME A MEMBER
THE RAILROAD UNION A BLACKSMITH
IN A LOCAL ELECTION SUPERVISOR
IN SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO WOULD BE
PROUD OF TODAY THANK YOU MEMBERS
AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS WE
WILL FIRST OPEN THE ROLL CALL
FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR ONE FIFTY
SIX OF MISTER MULLIN HAS
REQUESTED. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR ALL. OF THOSE WITH THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ON THIS M
SIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE
TO DECIDE TO VOTE. MEMBERS THEIR
SIXTY FOUR CO AUTHORS. WE WILL
NOW OPEN THE ROLE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
THIS B<c.cyan> NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT</c>
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MISTER
MULLIN YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTIONS. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE SPECIAL
GUESTS WE HAVE IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
MR ROBERT O'DRISCOLL WHO HAS
SERVED AS IRELAND'S GENERAL
COUNSEL ON THE RIGHT HERE- TO
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES IS
THAT SINCE JULY OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND HE WAS JOINED. ON
HIS RIGHT YOUR LEFT MISTER
MICHAEL MCGRATH HE'S THE IRISH
GOVERNMENT MINISTER FOR PUBLIC
EXPENDITURE AND REFORM A CABINET
MINISTER A ROLE HE HAS HELD
SINCE TWENTY TWENTY LET'S
WELCOME THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE FIVE
DIGNITARIES IN THE GALLERY HERE
TO COMMEMORATE. IRISH AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH. WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
THE CHANGES MEMBERS ANY VOTE
CHANGES AT THIS TIME MISSION
WHEN. WHEN SB ONE NINETEEN I TO
KNOW. CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLAN SENATE BILL ONE NINETEEN-
TO KNOW.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE WE VOTE
WILL FIRST TAKE A FILE ITEMS
FOURTEEN THROUGH SIXTEEN ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH APPROACH OF THE
GIRL SCOUTS OF THE USA ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FORTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ RELIGIOUS AMERICAN RED
CROSS MONTH. AND HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO YOU ON SUNDAY. CLICK
ON THE OPEN THE ROLE TWO. A CO
AUTHOR ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. ON THE
RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS ADDED
. NOW WE'RE MOVING TO A VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITSELF DOES
ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM CONSENT SEEING AND HEARING
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH RELATIVE TO THE
GIRL SCOUTS OF THE USA. AND THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CLERK WILL. CLOSER
ROLE. INTELLIA VOTE I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON CONSENT
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY NINE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO AND HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY
TWO I SIXTY SIX. NO. ZERO
MEMBERS WE HAVE SEVERAL
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THIS
AFTERNOON THE JOINT HEARING OF
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ONE AND
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FOR WILL
MEETS. AT TWO THIRTY PM WHICH IS
AT THIS MOMENT SO UPON A GERMAN
. THAT BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ONE
AND BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FOR
WILL MEET IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. JOINT HEARING OF THE
TRANSPORTATION AND NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE WILL ALSO
MEET UPON A GERMAN. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- TO. MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE MEETING
SCHEDULED FOR THIS THURSDAY.
WILL BE MOVED TO THE SWING SPACE
. TEN TWENTY ONE- STREET ROOM
ELEVEN HUNDRED THEY WILL MEET AT
EIGHT THIRTY AM PLEASE NOTE THE
LOCATION AND TIME CHANGE. AND
NOW WE ARE MOVING TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
. MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALLS IN
PLACE THE QUORUM CALL REMAINS IN
PLACE PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF FREDERICK HENRY READY
BOB IT WHO WAS A SON OF OAKLAND
AND A CAPTAIN WITH THE FREMONT
POLICE DEPARTMENT. FREDDIE WAS
BORN IN OAKLAND AND GREW UP IN
HIS FAMILY HOME ON EIGHTIETH
AVENUE FREDDIE WENT TO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN OAKLAND
HOPKINS MIDDLE SCHOOL IN FREMONT
AND GRADUATED FROM MISSION SAN
JOSE SCHOOL. IT WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL THAT FREDDIE BEGAN HIS
CAREER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE WHEN HE
JOINED THE FREMONT POLICE
DEPARTMENT. AS A POLICE EXPLORE
WHILE ATTENDING MISSION SAN JOSE
HIGH SCHOOL. HE BECAME A FREMONT
RESIDENT RESERVE POLICE OFFICER
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. AND
WAS PROMOTED TO POLICE OFFICER
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AND WAS
PROMOTED TO POLICE CAPTAIN IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. CAPTAIN BOBBITT
WAS RESPECTED BY HIS COLLEAGUES
AND ADMIRED BY THE COMMUNITY HE
SERVED. CAPTAIN BOB IT IS WIDELY
RECOGNIZED FOR TRAINING OFFICERS
UNDER HIS COMMAND. TO BE
COMMUNITY FRIENDLY EMBRACED
COMMUNITY POLICING BECAUSE HE
BELIEVED THAT TRUST AND
COOPERATION WITH THE YIELD THE
MOST EFFECTIVE RESULTS. CAPTAIN
BOBBY IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE.
ANNABEL MOTHER THREE DAUGHTERS
THREE SONS ONE OF WHOM IS A
POLICE OFFICER FOUR GRANDSONS
AND HIS SISTER AND HIS BROTHER
RAY MISTER BOB WILL BE DEARLY
MISSED BY SO MANY WHO KNEW THAT
HE PLACED FAMILY FIRST THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENSURE THAT WE
COULD HAVE A TRUSTING POLICE
SERVICE AND POLICE OFFICERS- IS
ENGAGE WITH OUR COMMUNITY AND
BY. ALL OF OAKLAND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS BONTA AND MR LEE
YOU TOO ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
GERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM ALSO RISING
TO REQUEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF CAPTAIN
FREDDIE H. BOB TODAY. HAVE YOU
HEARD FREDDIE GREW UP IN OAKLAND
AND WENT TO MISSION SAN JOSE
HIGH SCHOOL IN FREON WHICH IS A
HIGHLY COVETED. HIGH SCHOOL IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND DEDICATED HIS
LIFE TO SERVING OUR FREMONT
COMMUNITY AND ALAMEDA COUNTY AT
LARGE WHILE STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL
HE CONVINCES MOTHER TO ALLOW HIM
TO JOIN THE FREMONT POLICE
BERMAN IS AN EXPLORER IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE. WHILE
STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL AND HE
NEVER LOOKED BACK FURTHER
FREDDIE HONORABLY SERVE THE
FREMONT POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
COMMUNITY FOR FREMONT THE
FREMONT FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS RISING THROUGH THE RANKS
AND EVENTUALLY BECOMING CAPTAIN.
IS DEVOTED TO HIS WORK AND
HIGHLY DECORATING CLEAN BEING
SELECTED AS OFFICER OF THE YEAR
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR. FREDDIE
WAS BELOVED COLLEAGUE AND MENTOR
HE WAS WELL KNOWN PRESENCE IN
THE FREON COMMUNITY REPRESENTED
THE FREMONT POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND MANY CAN EVENTS AND
GATHERINGS AND I EVEN REMEMBER
WHEN YOU PARTICIPATE IN A DUNK
TANK. FREDDIE WAS TAKEN FROM US
UNEXPECTEDLY LAST MONTH AT ONLY
FIFTY FOUR YEARS OLD THIS IS A
BIG LOSS FOR OUR COMMUNITY. WILL
BE REMEMBER FONDLY AS A MAN WHO
LOVED HIS FAMILY AND LOVED OUR
COMMUNITY AND COULD MAKE A
FRIEND OF ANYONE HE MET HE MET.
WILL BE SORELY MISSED AND I
THINK IT'S A TESTAMENT TO THEIR
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT OF
THE MANY COMMUNITIES HE TOUCHED-
THAT ARE RISING IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY SO I REQUEST THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED. IN FREDDIE'S MEMORY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
LEYVA SURVEY APPROVED WELL ON
THIS IS GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK
MISTER SPEAKER. I TOO WOULD LIKE
TO JOURN IN MEMORY OF CAPTAIN
FREDDIE BOBBITT. A HERO TO THE
CITIES OF FREMONT. OAKLAND SAN
JOSE. AND TRACY WHERE HE LIVED
FOR THIRTY YEARS. AS MENTIONED
HE HE WAS ALWAYS STRIVING. TO
BEST SERVE THE COMMUNITY HE
WORKED AND LIVED AND CREATED A
SENSE OF. COOPERATION THE TRUST
AMONG PUBLIC. THE COMMUNITY
BASED APPROACH WAS ROUTED WITH
HIM. FROM A FROM AN EARLY AGE
THROUGH HIS PARTICIPATION OF U.
SPORTS VOLUNTEER AND ADDS THE
ALTAR BOY. IN SERVING AS A BOY
SCOUT. NOTHING MORE WAS
IMPORTANT TO HIM THAN HIS. AS A
PEACE OFFICER. HIS HIGHLIGHT
DECORATED CAREER INCLUDES
RECEIVING OFFICER OF THE YEAR IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE AND BEING
RECOGNIZED AS A COMMUNITY HERO
UP HUNDRED HERE ON THIS VERY OWN
GREEN FLOOR. WE HE LEAVES BEHIND
A LEGACY OF COMPASSION
UNDERSTANDING UNCONDITIONAL LOVE
AND COMMITMENT HE WILL BE DEARLY
MISSED BY COLLEAGUES HE HIM HE
MENTORED AND WORKED WITH EVERY
DAY HIS COMMUNITY THAT HE DEEPLY
INFLUENCE AND MOST OF ALL HIS
BELOVED FAMILY. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE ANNABEL IN HIS
MOTHER DELORES HIS BROTHER
SISTER AND SIX CHILDREN AND FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF CAPTAIN
FREDDIE BOBBITT. THANK HERE
MEANT THIS TO BE A GOOD ONE
THANK YOU MEMBERS. AND MR MEDINA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF ONE
THAT HE'S- ONE RED HILL WAS BORN
ON OCTOBER TWENTIETH NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE. IN MICHOACAN MEXICO
AND MOVIE NIGHT STATES AT A VERY
YOUNG AGE RESETTLED IN ORANGE
COUNTY. AND LIVED THERE FOR
SEVERAL DECADES OVERTIME ONE
LEARN THE PLUMBING TRADE AND
BECAME A UNION MEMBER AND
STARTED WORK AND DEVELOPING
CITIES OF IRVINE AND NEWPORT. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX HE MARRIED
IGNAZ SHIP ON DOHA THEY HAD TWO
CHILDREN. ONE OF HIS FAVORITE
MEMORIES WAS TAKING HIS CHILDREN
TO KNOTT'S BERRY FARM. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY HE MOVED HIS
FAMILY TO MARINO VALLEY AND
THERE HE BUILT HIS DREAM HOME
WHICH WAS COMPLETED IN FIVE
YEARS ONE LOVE GARDENING AND
PLANTED ORANGE AVOCADOS FIGS
LEMON APPLE GUAVA AND MANGO
TREES. WHERE THEY STAND STILL
TALL TODAY. ONE WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED BY HIS LOVED ONES AND I
ASK THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF ONE VIDEO
. THANK YOU MR MEDINA. MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS RICHARD IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED. IN THE JOURNAL SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
MARCH FIFTEENTH CHECK IN
SESSION. WEDNESDAY MARCH
SIXTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY MARCH SEVENTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION. IS AT NINE AM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN NO MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE. SEEING AND HEARING OF
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS REYES MOVES MR HOLDEN SECONDS
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MARCH SEVENTEENTH
AT NINE AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED.